أنا أستعد للقاء
رئيس الجمهورية ، أشعر بالقلق قليلاً
عندما تفوز بالميدالية الذهبية الوحيدة لبلدك
في أحدث الألعاب الأولمبية الصيفية ،
ستحصل على إشادة كبيرة من الأماكن المرتفعة ،
مرحبًا بأحمد ، تم رفع علم تونس
عالياً في الزوايا البعيدة
من العالم
، تم أخذ الميدالية باسم
تونس ، لكنك تضعها على
صدرك ،
فهذا مصدر فخر لجميع التونسيين ،
ليس فقط أنا
قد استمتعت بالمكافآت التي حصل عليها
بعد فوزه الكبير في طوكيو
ولكن الآن بعد أن عاد.  في المنزل مع
عائلته ، فإن الفوز التالي الذي يريده هو ضد
أخواته وألعاب الورق
أثناء الحجر الصحي ، لقد لعبنا
ألعاب الورق كثيرًا لعبناها كثيرًا ولكننا تشاجرنا كثيرًا أيضًا ، لقد
استمتعنا كثيرًا أليس
هذا صحيحًا
نعم إنه
أحمد يقول  لطالما كانت عائلته
تدعم شغفه بالسباحة ،
وكنا سعداء جدًا
لأننا كنا من الطبقة المتوسطة وكان ابننا
يسافر إلى الخارج ويسبح هناك ،
وقد حصل على العديد من الجوائز
ولكن الميدالية الأولمبية كانت نقطة تحول
في حياتنا.  خاصة بالنسبة له ،
إنها نقلة نوعية منذ أن أصبح
بطلاً أولمبيًا وليس من
السهل قبوله بالنسبة لنا
كعرب ومسلمين خاصةً سنه
في الواقع ، نحن ننتظر فقط ميدالية
وليست ذهبية ،
إنها حياة جديدة وعلينا أن  التكيف مع
ذلك ، حتى أن الصينيين لم يكونوا يتوقعون هذا
الإنجاز ،
نأمل أن يستمر في الأداء
بهذه الطريقة
بينما في المنزل ،
يتصرف أحمد كمراهق نموذجي يحصل على وجبات منزلية الصنع
من والدتي والوقت للاسترخاء
عندما أنتهي من التدريبات الخاصة بي أو أثناء
استراحة ، آخذ قسطًا من الراحة في غرفة نومي
وأشاهد الرسوم المتحركة ،
ألعب ألعاب الفيديو الضاحكة والكونتري سترايك
[الموسيقى]
الرسوم المتحركة والألعاب ممتعة ولكن أحمد
يقول إنه لا يزال يشعر بأنه في المنزل
عندما يكون بالقرب من الماء
أذهب إلى الشاطئ لأستريح  في روتيني ،
أحب الذهاب إلى الشاطئ مع
عائلتي وأصدقائي
كما ترون في تونس ، لدينا العديد من
الأماكن الجميلة
التي نتمتع بها حقًا
في البداية لم أكن أحب السباحة ولكن مع
مرور الوقت بدأت في التعود على
ثم وقعت في حبها في
كل مرة أحب السباحة فيها أكثر
فأكثر لأنني أعمل باستمرار على تحسين
مهاراتي بالطبع أقوم بتطوير مهاراتي
شيئًا فشيئًا كما لو كنت ألعب
لعبة على الإنترنت كل عام لديك
اختبارات جديدة  عليك أن تنجح ،
عليك تحسين مهاراتك والمضي قدمًا
كل عام ، فهناك تحديات جديدة